pathology of German postwar thinking gas
relationship um over over many decades
this is just Putin's War unil Society
basically prepared the the Putin regime
popularity of the annexation of Crimea
then became the pretext for the new
annexations there's not that much
difference anymore between dugin and
Putin control of the whole Black Sea
Coast he wanted the whole Black Sea
Coast yeah so the the problem is much
larger than than Putin he's a loser now
what's your opinion on Nal it's it's
more likely that you get hit in in Kev
by a car than by a by a missile the
history is happening here well my
beloved city is
Odessa hi everyone my name is Julia
timoshenko and you're watching a series
created by ukrainer in English in which
we talk to different journalists
academics and experts from different
countries and Fields about their
perspective on Ukraine the Russian
invasion and its Global impact and today
you have a chance to look at Ukraine
through the perspective of Andreas
umland a political scientist studying
contemporary Ukrainian and Russian
history and an analyst at Stockholm
Center for Eastern European studies
thank you so much Andreas for being here
thanks it's a big honor to speak to you
it's a likewise at first I wanted to
start with uh asking you how you got
interested in studying this region so if
you could walk me a little bit through
the moment when this interest was born
through your academic at large well as
you're saying how the interest was born
I was born to um in East Germany to a
Russian mother and like many other
Ukrainian lists um I came to study
Ukraine through first studying Russia
and I lived in Russia for a while and I
studied Russian Ultra nationalism um
wrote dissertations on such people as
Vladimir xowski and Alexander dugin and
then I um almost incidentally ended up
on a position here in in Kiev um at the
shevchenko University first um as a
visiting lecturer and then I fell in
love with Kev with Ukraine that was in
2002 and then I continued uh working
here and uh then learned Ukrainian after
a while and then also specialized more
and more in Ukraine I also stopped then
visiting at a certain point Russia
because the situation there became worse
and worse and I'm still studying Russia
especially the far right but also the
leadership of Russia but but now mainly
I focus um on Ukraine and on the war of
course yes and the the country is
fascinating it's also especially for a
political scientist um a fascinating
country and I know many colleagues in
the west who um Envy me for having lived
for such a long time here and and for
having this connection to Ukraine
because um they also look at this
country with a lot of sympathy and
interest was it difficult for you to
learn
Ukrainian not that much um I knew
already Russian well and um I picked up
I picked it up basically Ukrainian and
uh I never had actually a single lesson
uh of Ukrainian language I just uh read
it and listened to it and then started
speaking it and um now I feel not quite
as comfortable in um in Ukraine as in
English for instance which is my second
foreign language but I can now express
myself in Ukrainian that's great I think
it's very important when somebody who
studies this country specifically um
takes an effort to learn the language I
wanted to go back a little bit more to
your um PhD in politics and specifically
uh to your dissertation that you wrote
um that is called post Soviet and civil
society and the rise of Alexander Dugan
a case study of extra parliamentary
radical right in contemporary Russia in
which you basically explore the concept
of farite and the figure of dogen and
argue that basically although they
didn't became like a notable force in
the parliament in the '90s they still
remained a significant social and
political force could you expand a
little bit more on that well there's an
interesting parallelity here in that in
late 19th century Germany and in general
I would say I I came through to the
study of Russia through the study of uh
modern Germany uh inter War Germany es
especially in fascist Germany but um
also late 19th century Germany we had um
first rise in the 1870s of anti-Semitic
parties and then towards the end of the
19 century the anti-semitic parties
actually disappeared and it would have
seemed that because of the an
anti-semitic parties disappeared also
anti-Semitism would have disappeared but
that did not happen of course as we know
then from later history that uh the the
rather what happened was that
anti-Semitism became so widespread and
so much part of the general German
culture already um around the turn of
the century from the 19th to the 20th
century that these anti-semitic parties
in a way they lost their point and my
point in the um in the dissertation was
that the there was something similar in
the 1990s in in Russia that we had the
rise of xowski and of other far right
parties also the Communist Party of of
Russia became de facto a far-right party
and then the the Electoral support for
these parties fell in a way but of
course that did not mean that their
ideologies disappeared and their ideas
disappeared but um on the contrary um
they were picked up by people um not
fully and not entirely and not quickly
and not immediately but they were picked
up by people like um Vladimir Putin and
in a way now there is not that much
difference anymore between dugin and
Putin I would still say there is a
principal difference and one of them is
a revolutionary imperialist the other is
a conservative imperialist but they're
both very aggressive and so there was a
certain parallelity here in this uh
switch of party ideology into General
culture into the intellectual realm as
we had in Germany in the late 19th
century we had it in Russia in the late
20th century 100 years later basically
and that was an interesting parallelity
but well this is now all history now we
are already far I mean I wrote this in
the 1990s in the early 2000s when uh
when these developments um uh took place
I I wrote my first disseration on on
Jovi and then xowski became less
important and then it seemed that people
like duin became more important but Duan
was not a party politician and he he
never sort of um could demonstrate um
the relevance of his ideas by electoral
support he never became a political
figure but nevertheless I think he had
an impact on on post Soviet Russian
development and of course a very
negative one he was actually um you
could argue in the 1990s the first one
who formulated the current ideology of
Russian uh Ukraine policy not of the
Russian um General ideology not for
domestic affairs of Russia but what
Russia is now doing to Ukraine was
already written by dugi in his book ASN
politi the foundations of geopolitics in
1997 um almost um now almost 30 years
ago he formulated that and how would you
describe his formulation what was
specific well he wrote quite you know
the the area that is now annexed was by
by him already then identified as this
has to be we have to get control of the
whole Black Sea Coast he wanted the
whole Black Sea Coast right to
transnistria basically and and obviously
Russia wanted to do that too they wanted
to take Odessa and so on but they
couldn't but what what has now happened
actually was then actually prescribed by
by Putin he said you know Ukraine has no
right to exist um we need the Black Sea
area we you know we this country is not
a real country this is the things that
we are now he hearing from Putin medv
patev and so on um he he was more
radical and he is a revolutionary he
wants to create a new Russia a new world
that is not something that Putin wants
he wants rather restoration of the old
Empire so there is a difference between
them but um but the Ukraine policy in in
particular was something that dugin
basically formulated he was not the only
one that was another called um yini
marov in in the 1990s who also wrote
about novaria he then developed this um
this ideology of novaria and others
actually many of them um that and that
was actually the point of the um of the
dissertation that you mentioned that
there you have many of these civil or
unil Society actors and you know and
Duan was just a case study and maybe he
was not even the most important one of
all of these actors but uh but this unil
Society basically prepared uh the the
Putin regime and Putin's foreign
policy uh it sounds like you you talk
about the culture of Russia and that
also about the fact that there is not
only like the top down approach but also
bottom up in terms of this idea of like
new Russia new Russian World and
obviously we have as you say these un
Civil Society actors who play a big role
but
um I don't know if average Russian reads
Dugan specifically or his scientific
Works um but there is still like this
immense support among the Russian
Society towards the war in Ukraine and
towards the other Invasion that Russia
has done in the last 30 years and then
we have an argument of this is just
Putin's War this is just Putin in his
closed Club of members that wants this
but suddenly if somebody comes like a
new guy will have peace what do you say
to that specifically well the problem is
much deeper obviously it's also that you
know that was a little bit my direction
to which I came to Ukrainian studies so
other people they came to Ukrainian
studies perhaps why the study of culture
of the culture of the history and so on
of Ukraine but in a in a very strange
sense I I encountered Ukraine first as
an object of Russian imperialism in in
the 1990s when I was not yet here and I
studied janovski and and dugin and other
far-right extremists and they were
already obsessed with uh with Ukraine
and um so this is a wider
phenomenon um and there are different
aspects to it you have the a sort of
popular non-acceptance of Ukraine as a
state which is widely spread in the
population but which is not or which was
not violently and anti-ukrainian or
genocidal eliminationist Ukrainian and
then you have the ideologists like dugin
and and others and then you have also a
certain rationality be behind it so that
for instance the annexation of Crimea
was immensely popular in Russia and some
political scientists even argue and I'm
I also had myself the impression that it
was in spring 2014 more popular than
even uh Putin and the people around him
thought it would be so they had already
sentiment that this would be uh popular
but then you had really this sort of
Crimea consensus then appearing after
the annexation of Crimea and I think
this popularity of the annexation of
Crimea then became the pretext for the
new annexations uh because that was good
for the regime so there was also a
certain rationality here to to do that
and that has a lot to do with the vider
um non-acceptance in the Russian
population of the Ukrainian State I was
also just discussing this with a
colleague Anton shov
that since the start of the big Invasion
we never saw the attempt in Russia of a
general strike one can understand that
people don't want to go on the street
and to risk being anex um arrested and
so on but why was there no attempt to
Simply do a strike and stay at home for
two weeks or so and so and that
unfortunately seems to prove that the um
support for all of this is wider than we
would have thought um and it actually
supports the the opinion polls by the
levada center and so on that which are
often questions people say well they
people don't say what they think in
these in these polls but why was there
no then um general strike to prevent the
war but so uh yeah so the the problem is
much larger than than Putin obviously
but I think for the for the functioning
of the regime Putin is really important
so I still have a lot of Hope for the
moment that Putin disappears at some
point
because what I think then will happen is
that it will be very difficult for the
Clans to determine the successor of of
Putin they have no method of of
determining the successor and Putin has
now also lost um legitimacy and
Authority Putin cannot easily determine
a successor because he you know he has
now he's a loser now so if he says you
know this is going to be my successor it
may not be that the others will will
accept that and that will then hopefully
create instability domestic instability
and that will then hopefully then also
lead to political changes that will be
eventually beneficial to Ukraine well I
think Putin is definitely a loser for
the world but is he a loser inside
Russia because I think it's very easy
for him to create the impression that
he's not and it seems like a lot of
people at least from what we see buy
that idea but is there something that
tells you that in Russia he's also might
be considered a loser yeah maybe a loser
is is so far a too strong bird but um I
think he has definitely lost a lot of
authority since 24th of February uh
because before that he had the
annexation of Crimea he had a more or
less
successful sort of foreign policy in in
his his own
terms Russia was accepted U you know was
seen as important a major player and now
the Russian army is weak Putin is sort
of weak Uh Russian people in general
have become just unpopular um you see
that in the in the worldwide polls that
Russia is simply um much less popular
than it used to be and also I think the
the the Russian economy will more and
more then be hit by the um by the
sanctions the living standards will go
down the economy will not develop so I
think yeah I think at the end of the day
he will come out from all of this as a
loser and then there is also this sort
of perception of Naval in the world and
as this almost like the only hope for
future of Russia um a lot of people
perceived him that way a lot of people
still who support Ukraine they still
praise him and see him as this big great
figure that will come and suddenly bring
democracy and freedom and stop the world
and the war and the world will be become
better one the same day and there is
also ukrainians and also pretty much
every other nation that has suffered
from Russia who's very skeptical of this
figure because of his xenophobic
Expressions also one could argue farite
views what's your opinion on naal and on
the criticism and praise that he
receives in the west specifically I
cannot look into his head at the end of
the day I don't know how also he would
then behave once he gets power some If
he if that ever happens um I still would
would be rather hopeful uh because the
the statements he has recently made and
the development that I've seen in his
surroundings seems to indicate that he
has changed from his earlier nationalist
times when he wrote for instance um this
was just in the media now that there was
this assassination attempt on pin and he
once when naali Once wrote a forward for
a book by prapin and then he said you
know derogative things about ukrainians
about Georgians and so on but the um the
recent statement that he made that the
Declaration basically was okay you know
Crimea is is Ukrainian we should we
should get out of um Ukraine and all of
that you know these these people also
develop so I would still think of him as
a as a rather hopeful figure if he ever
gets out of prison and if he would get
uh I understand that ukrainians are
skeptical you
know there are lots of historical
examples why you would would be so but
in any way I think if he ever gets out
of prison and becomes president or prime
minister or whatever then um this will
be a very different Russia also a very
different Ukraine so I think that would
be actually a positive de development
it's simply one of the figures that we
have you know we cannot and we have to
deal with what what's there I mean I
know for inst Vladimir karura personally
very well he is um an intellectual and
um I like him a lot um and he never had
these sort of ambivalent episodes in his
um in his biography as navali and others
have had but he I don't think is a major
political figure so far at least not in
in Russia whereas Naval is so you know
here I would be rather pragmatic and see
as the best hope perhaps still for
Ukraine well obviously we can't really
judge how sincere he is in those
statements because um a lot of those
statement specifically on Crimea and
also on apologizing to Georgians or
something that he recently put out on
his Twitter um that probably made by his
team I don't think he actually tweets
from their prison although I might be
wrong um a lot of them seem like they
came under the pressure that has been
shown by a lot of ukrainians Ukrainian
activists uh just advocates for Ukraine
from abroad and also I think nal's team
is smart enough to understand that in
order to be more wildly accepted in the
west they need to put out these
statements but whenever there is a
question about reparations and things
like
responsibility um of Russian people and
uh what's coming next after this I think
that's where he's still not very firm
because maybe that is something that
will make him essentially unpopular in
his own
country do you think it's even possible
to Hope with him that we will get the
restorative justice that we demand as
ukrainians from a figure who's still
very hesitant
to talk directly about it well that's I
mean you know that so many things would
have to happen before that becomes then
um actually uh a topical and uh an
urgent as salent
question um I've talked to one of his
Close Associates Vladimir milov U Who
belongs to his team and from the way he
talks about this yes I would say that
they they acknowledge that there has to
be reparations there has to be this
restorative justice U and people have to
be to put in in prison and have to go to
court those who are
guilty um and yeah and that is the the
question of guilt but then um and we
know that from I know that from German
history then there a question of
responsibility yeah so and that is that
is indeed um a difficult question um we
had that in Germany too that people
after World War II were saying well I
didn't know you
know we didn't couldn't do anything you
know was a dictatorship and so on so
that that will be certainly also there
in in in Russia and also in Germany we
had I mean the first uh governments of
Germany they were not
very you know they acknowledged the
guilt they acknowledged also
responsibility but there was no
immediate forit this coming to term with
the past this sort of uh recognizing
fully um the responsibility that came
only later but um I think we have to
deal with what we've got uh you know is
um if there were more popular other
Russian politician with less problematic
episodes in his past or her past then I
would probably prefer that person but I
don't see anybody comparable to him but
um but in any way it may be a very
theoretical discussion because whether
he ever gets out of prison and whether
he will be healthy but if he gets out
whether he will not die in prison um you
know we don't know know yet so this is
all very theoretical so far um yeah and
then it's very interesting what you're
talking about uh Germany specifically
and uh just over all German Society
coming to terms and understanding the
collective responsibility and also the
not just on the top level of the
government but also the personal level
um do you think that the Russian people
ever would be able to see Ukraine and
then the rest of I guess the region and
the world
without their imperialist
bias
and do you believe that they will ever
be able to accept the responsibility for
the crimes well the the German
experience again is that basically yes
that is possible I mean still I would
argue that the you know the the German
crimes they are of a higher order than
the Russian crimes uh so far what do you
mean by that specific well you know
there were 50 million dead and gas
Chambers and so on
so it's what is now happening in Ukraine
is terrible but but still the um the
overall if you count it simply and also
in terms of the
um inhalation um the Holocaust is
something specific you know and I mean
there's a pathology that goes even
deeper than the current Ukraine phobia
of of of Russia with uh with gas Embers
and so on but we are not at the end of
the story you know can be here even
worse I mean that unfortunately one
cannot exclude it yeah I mean you know
this some people say that what would
have to happen is actually that the
current Russian state would have to
disappear in its current form for the
Imperial impulse to disappear so that
could be true and it's actually what
happened to Germany the the old German
State disappeared it was divided and
then it later
reunified um and anyway the even the
reunified now current German state is
much smaller than the previous German
state so maybe something like that would
have to happen um to Russia too you know
this is all a lot of speculation now one
one thing to to get away from this
Imperial past and impulse I've written
about that with a with a colleague
before Valentina Romanova is
decentralization maybe a
decentralization on the model of the UK
ukan decentralization of all models so
that you would transfer power in a in a
reconstituted Russia to the local level
and a lot of power to the local level
the cities the uh the local communities
and then perhaps politics and the
political thinking would would change
that that may be an alternative to um to
the breakup of of the country because
then people would would be more engaged
with the local Affairs of their of their
Village or of their
City and now I want to talk a little bit
more about perception of Ukraine in
Academia specifically and how it has
changed or not changed yet because as
someone who also studied in American
University and has seen these Russian
studies programs that sometimes are
called Eastern European or Slavic
studies and when you just swipe through
the courses or um just the program offer
it it's usually very Russia Centric and
even if it provides any kind of view on
any other culture country region part of
the region in Eastern Europe it's
usually from the Russian perspective and
then you have the Decades of us and
European academics traveling to Russia
doing this intellectual exchange
studying Russia but again from Mostly
from that Moscow based perspective
what's your opinion on that just in
general as somebody who specifically I
guess encountered Ukraine as you
mentioned uh through your studies of
Russia and do you think that Academia in
general is changing and decolonizing its
view perhaps on other parts of Eastern
Europe I haven't been I've been in
Russian studies in sorry in Ukrainian
studies for the last 20 years and before
that as I mentioned I was in in Russian
studies so I don't know that well
actually um Ukrainian studies I've been
to the major centers in in Edmonton and
in in in Harvard in in England and so on
so but um I I wouldn't know as as well
the the history of Ukrainian studies as
perhaps other experts whom you may
interview here but what in Russian
studies was always a problem I think
that there was
a and that's also why I studied then
eventually shinski and and Dugan is an
inattention to these pathological traits
in Russian political thought and the
especially the Imperial uh trades and
that is still expressed for instance in
this very bizarre term of Eurasian um
which is in in the in the names of many
of these centers and so on the problem
here being that when when the term
Eurasian is is um used what is meant is
not the Euro Asian um mega continent the
whole of Europe and the whole of of of
Asia but something else and it's also
not Central Asia sometimes when it it
says Central Eurasian I can sort of
understand then it's Central Asia simply
the Central Asian former Soviet
republics but what is Eurasia actually
when you use it in this for this post
Soviet sphere because that is then
actually a Proto fascist term because
that comes out of eurasianism and that
is the idea that there is some sort of
special
civilization between Europe and Asia
this sort of uh you know special sphere
and that goes back then to the
eurasianists and these eurasianists they
were very different from the current
so-called Neo eurasianism of dugin you
know so actually there isn't that much
connection between dugin's Neo
eurasianism and the classical
eurasianists of the 1920s and 1930s but
the way they used Eurasia it was
actually a Proto fascist term it was the
idea that there's a
civilization sort of unknown
civilization between Europe and and Asia
with the center Moscow and it has to be
sort of new born and new rediscovered uh
reborn and um a colleague of M Leon Lui
had already written about this um 30
years ago that there's a lot of um diff
similarity between these eurasianists
who shaped the term Eurasian and Eurasia
and eurasianism of the 1920s 1930s and
in the diaspora the Russian diaspora was
not in Soviet Russia and the German
conservative Revolution um these were
these intellectuals who basically
prepared the rise of of Hitler they were
not part of the Nazi movement but they
had also this sort of idea of a special
German path and so on and they
undermined the viar Republic and and
they are in generally in Germany held to
be partly responsible for the decline of
the um of the first um uh German
democracy and and the eurasianists were
structurally in their thinking very
similar to the um to the German
conservative revolution revolution
therefore the the use now of this term
Eurasian studies is is very very dubious
actually it it it puts into question you
know indeed what you what you mentioned
that there's something wrong there's too
much sort of U I would say tolerance
towards these um Imperial view of this
of this space as something Eurasian that
is some somehow connected with each
other and so on so so um yeah but but
actually I'm quite optimistic um
concerning um these changes now finally
of course too way too late and but not
too little anymore so there there was
already before Ukrainian studies were
was already developing before now
finally it's changing the East European
studies um and post Soviet studies are
changing very deeply and I think there's
now a lot of critical self-reflection in
in the west about this and um so I think
that was a problem and I think that was
also one of the reasons that the West
reacted so late and so little to all of
this that it did not react sufficiently
in 2014 and in 2008 uh when Russia
invaded
Georgia but it is now finally um this
process has started and as I see from
the sort of social media there's now
almost every month there is some sort of
conference or or project that wants to
reform um uh the the Western study of of
Eastern Europe it's very actually
interesting that you mentioned that you
uh you connect this to the reason why
the West was so slow in responding or
unresponsive at all to the 2014 Invasion
to invasion of Georgia uh because
universities and these academic spaces
that's where the knowledge uh is being
created and is being spread then and if
you I guess study Russia is this great
country culture and you completely erase
the conversation about everything else
like almost bad that they've done and
the story of any other indigenous people
of these regions just you know the idea
of just even the Ukrainian language like
the the things that people who were
studying those Eurasian studies or
Slavic studies and they were completely
Miss saying like the basic I guess
understanding of the the region so um I
think like I also really see that
connection of why so many people were
surprised suddenly in 2022 that Russia
invaded Ukraine and weren't really
seeing it coming what do you think I
guess um as somebody who also is
connected to Ukrainian Academia um what
do you think Ukrainian Academia needs to
do to Foster this connections between uh
different academic institutions around
the world uh and to make sure that
Ukrainian studies and understanding of
this region from also our perspective um
increases overall that's a good
question uh I mean you know do more I
mean to to say something
qualitatively novel is um is difficult
sometimes what I observe but again that
that is a very personal observation is
that there
is and maybe that is a bit too critical
now and and maybe even insensitive when
I'm saying there's too much advocacy uh
sometimes I think you can go more now
especially to Western audiences with
information with analysis you don't need
to say that you know you you don't need
to portray your country anymore in a in
an advocating manner because the the
front lines are clear already you can
come with information with analys with
details people will be more interested
at least in in the circles I'm I'm in
you know I've been to many of these
events where ukrainians were invited and
they were
basically presenting an advertisement of
Ukraine which was not necessary anymore
because the people in the audience were
already on Ukraine side what they wanted
was details analysis
scenarios um the you know comparisons so
sort of more information so you can now
actually
um proceed from the fact that there's a
lot of interest actually and now you
literally have to feed the interest with
with information and you don't need to
say anymore sometimes people they seem
to think well you know you you come
there and you say you know Russia is bad
and then you see there's no reaction to
it and then people think well we should
say that now that Russia is very bad
maybe then then we'll get something but
the problem is not that people don't
understand that Russ is bad but they
they want to hear some information they
don't want to be told once more but they
already know um so that is do they want
to hear like why like the answer of that
do they want to hear more background
yeah I mean I think the what you can
what you can sometimes um I think
ukrainians and in General East Europeans
they can provide information about
Russia that people in the west will not
know and here you can also you can you
can um speak about let's say the
suppression of U um Ukrainian language
in the tarist Empire you know the um all
the the and and and here you can come
with with information rather than with
saying you know Russia was always bad
under under the Zars and you know it's
rather that you illustrate that with
details and with you say you know well
they you know what we've heard what we
hear now from Putin you could already
hear from the tars you know
um almost 200 years ago and if you can
then illustrate that that will have an
effect you know that is something that
people may not know yet but it's more
about analysis and and and information
than about advocacy so but that is
something that of course is also shaped
by by the particular conferences and
meetings I'm going to and often you have
actually people from the West sitting in
the audience that are actually reading
on Ukraine every day and then you know
comes a Ukrainian delegation and tells
them we've been always Europeans
Russians have always been um you know
authoritarians yeah of course we know
but now you know we here in an expert
meeting and we want to know some
information now something what is
happening with the economy with uh with
culture with society and so on and and
sometimes these these opportunities are
then lost um in an odd way um and it's
not good for Ukraine simply lost
opportunity and lost time lost energy
that's a very interesting point and um
and suggestion I think just overall how
to improve that kind of communication
because I see it more as a communication
problem and I totally understand
probably people in those circles because
when you come to this intellectual
spaces where people have a privilege to
just read about these things but you're
family or you know or you're yourself
impacted by this I think it also impacts
the way you talk and sometimes it's
probably really hard to separate
yourself from that so maybe that's where
advocacy comes comes from but I think
your point is very valuable yeah then
the OD thing is that the people who are
doing the advocacy are usually very well
informed so they have the information
you know they know the details the
numbers you know and the the facts and
so on but they they feel that they have
to make some advertisement which is
which is not necessary anymore I mean
now especially now I mean after the
start of the war and now Russia is
discredited to such a degree anyway I
mean you know Putin is discrediting the
country now to to such a degree that you
don't need to tell um at least the more
more sane people in the west anymore
that um this is really an evil regime M
now I would like to turn a little bit to
your work in Stockholm um in Sweden and
Sweden is holding the presidency of the
Council of the EU until June I believe
uh so for this half of the Year what's
your impression about their presidency
overall and what are the main issues
that uh the Council of EU is dealing
right now in ear to Ukraine first I have
to say I'm not Swedish so I'm not so
deep in and I also don't read Swedish um
it's a Germanic language but um um it's
not actually very similar to to German I
thought it would be easy I would like
pick it pick it up like I I did once
with with Ukrainian but so far it
doesn't work at all so I'm not so deep
in the um in the Swedish um discourse
and as weed would perhaps also then talk
about this differently but what I do
know is that Ukraine is really a major
topic for perhaps even the major topic
for the um Swedish um presidency and um
I would even say it's a major Topic in
general for Swedish politics not just
for foreign policy um it's extremely
present the as you may know the the
sympathy for Ukraine in Sweden is
exceptionally high it's actually higher
than in my in my home country in Germany
where you have these sort of uh
ambivalent especially in East Germany I
come from East Germany you have these
bizarre um still uh Putin F and um
this very bizarre discourses that is U
Not absent in in Sweden but is much
smaller it's marginal there so there's a
lot of of sympathy a lot of attention
for Ukraine and yeah and and Sweden is
is one of the best best I would say
Western um partners of um of Ukraine
that has um been already
earlier proven by for instance the um
the Eastern partnership program that
Poland and Sweden together initiated so
and um it's also by the dispop
disproportionate um amount of help that
Sweden is providing so Sweden is a small
country it's not as large as Germany but
um it's providing a lot of help in
various ways military help um in other
directions so it's um uh yeah so Sweden
is basically you know um one of the best
Partners um again here often the the the
the question is rather the technicality
um again it's about details and
information how to implement actually
the good intentions that are already
there and how to make them most
effective you don't need to persuade
people there anymore this is this is
different maybe in other European
countries you know in Italy or Greece
Austria you know Hungary these are
countries where you still have large
parts of the PO iCal Elite that are sort
of um with rather strange geopolitical
views but um but countries like Sweden
they are very supportive of of Ukraine
do you think that um the support from
Sweden and other noric countries is
shaped by history in any way of their
own relations with Russia or Russian
Empire and Soviet Union well that's a
good question for that I don't know the
history of Sweden and of other nor
Northern countries
well enough um the odd thing for me as a
German here is to see that um the German
and and Swedish General outlook on the
world is on an abstract level not so
dissimilar but at the end of the day
then Sweden and and
Germany at least before the start of the
large Invasion last year came out on
different parts um of their sort of
foreign policy so Sweden was much more
supportive of of Ukraine and although it
it's still not a member of NATO it had a
much much more realistic view of um of
Russia and was relative to its size very
supportive of Ukraine although although
and and in Germany that was less so the
case you had this this sort of
infatuation with Russia um which has now
gone down fortunately too late uh but
not too little actually anymore now it's
actually changing um I'm now actually
getting more optimistic um especially in
the last half year regarding Germany
because there is now a deep uh change in
the whole political Outlook and you have
now new books coming out that are very
critical of the former policies it's not
yet done it's not the done job but there
is a very good development there in
Sweden that is not necessary because you
had already a rather good uh foreign
policy there already why that is the
case um it's difficult to say I mean
it's it's largely the same of course
with with Finland but but with Finland
well it's it's not the same actually the
fins have of course another another they
have their own history with with Russia
so um but the fins are and swedes are
very close now in or have been already
for a long time very close in their
viewpoint on on Russia
so um I don't know I'm for that I'm
frankly have to say I don't know Sweden
well enough to give a good answer to
that well that was I think a good enough
perspective and answer and since you
mentioned Germany a lot and you're
German I think we've seen a lot of
hesitation from Germany since the start
and you wrote about it actually and some
of your articles in Ukraine um about
that blind spot in Germany's foreign po
policy when it comes to military help to
Ukraine because uh Germany and the
government was very helpful in taking
Ukrainian refugees and providing
humanitarian and other kinds of aid but
when it came to uh the weapons that's
where the situation was completely
almost like ridiculous at some points um
we've heard like different arguments
such as like oh we can't allow like a
German tank uh hit like a Russian tank
again so there's a lot of historic
memory and maybe that responsibility
about which we've talked about that
comes into play but it seems like in a
lot of those aspects German government
is completely missing the point of
what's Happening um could you elaborate
a little bit on that and just overall
why do you think that's the case I would
say the Dark Side of um the German
so-called OS politic of I would say the
last 50 years uh and we had already
bizarre developments in the 1980s when
there was this special relationship with
the East German Communist Party the
Socialist Unity party and the Social
Democratic party um and then you know
the skepticism to toward the solidarity
movement in um in Poland um so that is
not a new a new thing that goes back
much further some people even say that
goes back to the interwar period um the
rapalo treaty and so on so there were um
these long lines of special relations
between Russians and Germans as the two
largest numerically largest nations of
Europe and you know who have this sort
of Z faan the the unity of the souls or
the the closeness of the souls you know
and this sort of mutual cultural
interest and and and all of that that
has then also had an effect on the um on
the foreign policies and the economic
policies we had then this gas
relationship um over over many decades
um with the Soviet Union already um
starting that is a very embarrassing
story and um and that then mixed up with
with General German pacifism um and in a
way the pacifism was perhaps something
good at certain point after World War II
the Germans became pacifist better
pacifist than the than the other extreme
uh but that became then a very
unrealistic sort of view of of Eastern
Europe when Putin came to power that was
perhaps still Justified with yelen I
think there were yelson was a more
ambivalent figure some people people see
more continuity I think you know yelson
was a different political animal but
with Putin then this this sort of
pacifist tradition became really a
problem for the um for Eastern Europe in
general this is now changing finally
it's too late now in a way we have the
big escalation the military help that
Germany is now providing should have
been provided two years ago then perhaps
we would not have this war now um but
that was not possible there by uh German
politician um uh harbec um who is now
the Minister of Economics was in in
summer uh I think it was
2021 in the donbas and he was then uh
suggesting that Germany should deliver
weapons to Ukraine and that caused then
a big Scandal um and was unspeakable
still but now we are finally delivering
weapons and uh more and more significant
uh weapons happens better late than
never um it's it's still I think too
little um so we could still do more uh
but it's also an evolution and the
evolution so far is going in the right
um right direction why this has I mean
that it's a it's a complicated mixture
of sort of uh misjudgment of economic
interests of um some sort of
infatuation with with Russia and it's
for different figures for different
politicians it's different things and
shudo was here of course the I mean he's
the worst of all and in in an odd way he
comes from a from a leftwing tradition
so you would think that from a leftwing
party you think that this would be make
him sort of more attentive to the ideas
or to the to the interests of the of the
weaker of the smaller of the those who
need help but it was oddly um exactly
the way around in a way he was in his in
his foreign policy attitude he was an
imperialist in supporting the Russian
imperialism he was in in a in the German
conservative tradition sort of um in a
very odd way um but um yeah that's a
that's a pathology of German post-war
thinking um and that's where we still
have not gotten fully over our um
pathologies in our sort of national
memory but but there's now actually a
process going on that makes me
optimistic books coming out that
criticizing that a lot and I hope there
will be also then some parliamentary
commission we will have actually a
formal process of a critical reflection
of all of this what's the cataclysm of
that change because the the moment of
the invasion didn't make it happen it
you said you mentioned like the last
half a year that like changed a little
bit and you mentioned that some uh
German politicians coming actually and
visiting Ukraine and see in the front
lines and then understanding do you
think that there are specific maybe
actors who are driving that change
within Germany you mentioned the books
being written out or is it some sort of
just natural cultural process as well or
maybe Ukraine also is working you know
on their diplomacy with Germany how do
you see that well the uh the official
German reaction was rather fast and
rather decisive that was the um famous
titon vender the changing of times
speech of um Chancellor Schultz on I
think the 27th of February uh 3 days
after the large Invasion started um and
he then said we we are now living in a
different different era and we have to
change uh so on the official level uh
actually the reaction was rather Swift
and um I was even at that moment at
least by the speech itself positively
surprised because it um it was very
clear and but then the um the actual
adaptation of the Practical policies was
too slow you know the decisions on
delivery of weapons came too slow and
what perhaps have has then changed the
perception in Germany were simply the
Ukrainian refugees and the the hundreds
of thousands we have now around 1
million Ukrainian refugees and that was
something so present that the old sort
of um it
delegitimized the the old uh narratives
and then
um as in my feeling there was then the
the actual the large social change and
and and the large change in the
political Elite in um in Autumn I would
say last year um 20 uh 22 when we when
then there were also the decisions
forthcoming you know then on um on the
heavy weapons on first these were the
anti-aircraft weapons the artillery and
then finally also um the tanks and and
now we have books coming out that
criticize that and now there is a is a
re rethinking going on what we still
don't have is a is a commission a
parliamentary commission that would
actually reflect on all of this in a
more official way and um the problem
here being is of course that the
representatives of the old policy are
still in power um like uh our federal
president Frank valter Stein Meer who is
a a former associate of schrder and
basically came through through shudder
into politics is U is still there he has
he has admitted his mistakes and more so
than others so um he's in a way recently
also a more positive example but we need
a much much deeper and much more
official uh critical reflection on on
the mistakes of the past you mentioned
that you wish that Germany uh would do
more specifically militaristically as
well um to those who are skeptical could
you answer why why should Germany
support Ukraine more especially on
Military um well I think the M now the
main thing is that the often the
argument is we have certain obligations
within NATO and that's why we need our
own weapons because but the odd thing
about this whole uh argument is that the
um the two things have have now changed
first it has turned out that NATO has
prepared itself against um a Russian
army that never existed apparently in
the way that we thought it would exist
because the the last year has shown that
the Russian army is is much less
effective than um than many in NATO
thought and then that is only one odd
thing the other odd thing is that the
NATO plans that are still there now and
the whole sort of setup of NATO is
geared towards a Russian army that
partly doesn't exist anymore so we are
fighting F in in a way dead Souls so we
we have sort of obligations for instance
the German Army has now obligations in
NATO to defend NATO against Russian
units that have been destroyed in
Ukraine so they're they're not existent
anymore so we could we could give much
more that is actually what the what for
instance the Baltic countries I mean
they they've giving everything they can
because they they know that you know the
the tanks let's say the Russian tanks
that are going to be destroyed in
Ukraine are not going to be a threat to
to the Baltic countries anymore which is
much more rational thinking and you
would think that Germans are rational
but but we are not often actually where
there's a lot of sort of um um emotional
U thinking here going on if you want to
call it that way so this is a problem
that we are still in this sort of you
know we have to we have our obligations
we have international uh sort of and but
we we cannot we cannot step away from
this from this old world uh from before
24th of February 20 2022 so we should
make finally this step and and um and
then we can also send more although one
has to say Germany does not have that
much it's not I think Germany will
become for for Ukraine much more
important when uh when there will be
finally peace and when the
Reconstruction will start in full I
think then the Germans will actually
engage a lot because that's something we
can do we have
experience you know we have the
structures we have institutions we have
organ ations we have people who have
done that in in in Latin America and
Africa and Asia and so on that's
something we do yeah we don't fight Wars
anymore so there's now something there
was also a miscommunication or a
misperception perhaps between Ukraine
and Germany that many in here seem to
think of Germany as a sort of a major
military power which we are not I mean
we have a military industry
technologically we do produce certain
military stuff uh well but we don't have
we are not a country with with a large
army and and the large military so there
was a little bit of a miscommunication
here also from the or misperception or
misconceived expectations from the
Ukrainian side for some things Germany
is not the ideal partner uh like for
some of the military issues um that's
also one of the reasons why we have not
helped perhaps as much as I would also
wish I would still say we could help
more but part of the story is also that
we don't have simply that much stuff
that we can give Ukraine mhm yeah at
least not blocking some transfers yes
that would be yeah yeah that was that
was very embarrassing before the uh I
mean there were these requests from
other countries that had German weapons
and then Germany would not I mean that
these were really scandalous decisions
yeah but uh I mean talking to you makes
me hopeful that uh that as you say
something is changing and hopefully
we'll see more proactive uh at least
when it comes to transferring partner
weapons to Ukraine as well uh proactive
St from Germany specifically uh last
summer you also wrote an open letter to
your International colleagues where you
uh basically called on um the
international political science
international relations uh experts
Community to visit a wartime Ukraine
because you basically said that the
history is happening here now how did
you come to that idea specific
specifically and why do you think that
the history in Ukraine is right now uh I
mean obviously we know geopolitically
but why being specifically in Kev or any
other part of Ukraine is something that
is valuable for people of your
background for example this has been
this article came out in several
languages and several uh settings has
been criticized also people have said
well this is wartime um tourism um and
that there's a certain voyerism um
associated with that you know uh but the
point of the of the article was actually
that both traveling to Kiev and Kev
itself is actually pretty safe uh and
that uh um of course we have now these
frequent attacks and I've wrote this
article in last summer when it was
actually that was this Qui period and
then I was here in October when the when
the bombardment of civil uh civilian
infrastructure uh started I was actually
in observing that from my um window in
um here in Kiev the uh the hits on then
on on Kev so that was already slightly
different but still as you of course
know much better than than me it's it's
more likely that you get hit in in Kev
by a car than by a by a missile um so um
so the point was simply to say well to
my colleagues political scientists you
have your um um history happening and
you can go here it's a little bit
inconvenient but there is now there are
now different trains you can come here
with and buses and so on and routes that
you can come here and you can observe um
history here and also what I think is
that and and some people have criticized
that they they say some ukrainians have
criticized that they have said you
shouldn't come now you these people
should come after the war yeah they're
very welcome but after the war not now
you know that because that is dangerous
and so on but um you know I mean we live
only one time and uh you want to you
know when history is happening here and
and at the end of the day um at least if
you visit the cities in Ukraine that are
not directly um involved in sort of
wartime War efforts where you have
significant civilian life the arrival of
tourists will not be a strain to the
infrastructure on the contrary it will
will actually bring money it will
actually you know good be be good for
businesses here if you go here and if
you and then you bring firsthand
experiences back and so on so that is
good for for Ukraine's integration
europeanization Partnerships with
Western countries so on the whole there
were some arguments against it and some
of them are valid you know in a way it
is wartime tourism in a way of course
the Ukrainian infrastructure is now year
to Ward the war effort but I think on
balance um if people come here who are
well prepared to do that who have maybe
acquaintances here who are uh coming
here with a purpose who um who can sort
of contextualize that on balance I think
there are more arguments in favor of
inviting people to come here and I don't
think it's irresponsible some people
have said it's irresponsible to to say
that but I don't think it is I mean I'm
now being here and even now that in the
last week here there were lots of of
attacks on KF but most of the um or at
actually all of them as far as I know
all of the flying objects that have
recently um in the last week been sent
from Russia to Kev have been shut down
so there was no no actually hit in in
Kev so I don't think it's irresponsible
to to invite people to come here and if
you are a political scientist I mean or
a historian I mean that's what we're
studying I mean that's our business and
and then to to to sit somewhere in your
office in in North America or Western
Europe is ridiculous if you can actually
come here and it's relatively safe and
you have you know the hotels are working
the restaurants are working the banks
are working it's all it's all there and
you you don't need a visa you can just
get on the train and come and yeah and
talk to people actually instead of yeah
I think there is many ways in which you
can do it ethically obviously we've seen
examples of War tourism and voyerism and
people coming from outside and not being
very ethical in the way they portray
there a time in Ukraine at this at this
specific time uh but there's also as you
said large economic benefits and just uh
if you do it right there is it
outweights obviously the kind of the
arguments against that um lastly I guess
we've talked about so many uh topics and
it's been a pleasure to talk to you and
hear your uh opinions about all of these
things what's your personal favorite
place in Ukraine that you would
recommend to other people to visit mhm
well my beloved city is Odessa I have to
say you know it's just why well just the
combination that you have a very
convenient and and and you know very
Lively city with the sea with beaches
you know and that's just a unfortunately
right now it's not yeah I know I know
that's
um but that's also because I'm I like
water a lot so and I also do ice bathing
in the winter and so on um here in the
nepro as well so um
but but there you know I have everything
I you I have a nice city excellent
restaurants beautiful architecture and
and beaches so what else do you
need well that's beautiful uh thank you
so much it's been a pleasure talking to
you and uh thank you everyone for
watching we had Andres omland with us a
political scientist and an analyst and
we've talked about many topics relating
to Ukraine Germany and the overall
impact of the Russian invasion on the
world if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to Ukraine and English Channel
and stay tuned for next video in this
[Music]
series